In this video we are going to talk about
collision detection and collision
avoidance. So before we do that, let's
imagine there's a room and there are,
like, three different people and when two
people are talking, the third person, if
he tries to talk, the conversation
becomes difficult for the other two
people. In the same way,
let's say we have three different
computers on the same network. Now if A
was talking to B and C suddenly
transfers data to A there is a
collision and when this collision
happens the original message from A to B
becomes garbage.
It's of no use anymore because there is
interference. So when there is a
collision that happens A detects it and
it backs off before it tries to send a
message back to B again. So this was in
the original days of the networking but
later
what happened is, they added the concept of collision avoidance. So in that, what
happens is: C, before it actually
starts sending data to A, it tries to see
if there is a conversation going on
already before it sends. So that's CA
or Collision Avoidance.